Bentornato a Quantum Computing in Practice. Questo episodio si concentrerà sul primo e spesso il più
impegnativo passo nella definizione di un programma quantistico: mappare un problema generale su un circuit che può essere eseguito su un computer quantistico.
Questo passo descrive come un utente che parte da un dato problema computazionale
può tradurlo in modo che un computer quantistico possa comprenderlo.
Nelle lezioni precedenti di questa serie, le lezioni due e tre, abbiamo discusso che la fase di mapping è il primo passo
su quattro nel framework Qiskit patterns. Da quelle lezioni, potresti ricordare che il nostro obiettivo era tradurre
o riscrivere un problema computazionale in una funzione di costo o un valore di aspettativa
che possiamo valutare usando un computer quantistico.
Nella lezione tre, abbiamo discusso un esempio concreto con il max cut, un problema
computazionalmente difficile e molto comune nell'ottimizzazione combinatoria.
In quell'esempio, abbiamo seguito diversi passi per trasformare il grafo iniziale in un problema nativo quantistico. Abbiamo
trasformato il problema di trovare il numero massimo di tagli nel grafo in una funzione di costo, poi riscritto quella funzione di costo
come Hamiltoniano e preparato uno stato quantistico di prova il cui stato fondamentale
corrisponde al max cut. Infine, abbiamo costruito un quantum circuit che rappresenta lo stato quantistico di prova di
interesse e poi aggiunto i gate specifici per consentire allo stato di evolversi nel tempo. Questa sequenza di passi è ciò che
chiamiamo mapping. E ad alto livello, la procedura è generale a molte altre applicazioni come la chimica quantistica
e la simulazione quantistica. Ora, non c'è modo di aggirare il fatto che il mapping può essere difficile. Non esiste una
strategia universale per ogni singolo problema, quindi può essere intimidatorio. Oggi, metterò in evidenza
alcuni esempi rappresentativi di problemi diversi e descriverò come sono stati mappati in ciascun caso. Farò rapidamente un
ripasso di ciò che abbiamo imparato sui problemi di grafi come quelli usati nel Max Cut e dedicherò il resto della lezione a
come mappare problemi che appaiono in natura, come problemi di struttura molecolare in biologia, problemi di
struttura elettronica in chimica e simulazione di teorie quantistiche di campo in fisica delle alte energie.
Ma prima di dedicare la maggior parte del nostro tempo in questo episodio ad esaminare problemi di esempio dalla letteratura, voglio darti
una panoramica ad alto livello delle cose principali che vogliamo realizzare e considerare quando mappiamo un problema. Ci sono
alcune cose da considerare per qualsiasi tipo di problema computazionale che dovrà essere tradotto in un quantum circuit.
Prima di tutto, potresti dover semplificare il problema per renderlo fattibile. Questo è qualcosa di comune alla maggior parte delle discipline scientifiche.
Non è esclusivo del quantum computing. Se hai mai sentito l'espressione "assumi una mucca sferica",
allude al fatto che spesso è difficile descrivere un sistema esattamente come appare. Ma
invece, possiamo fare semplificazioni ragionevoli che possono comunque portare a soluzioni utili.
Alcuni esempi di come potremmo farlo nel quantum computing sono limitare la dimensione o la profondità del circuit scegliendo un
ansatz efficiente per l'hardware, o troncare evoluzioni temporali complesse, o trascurare
i termini dell'Hamiltoniano che contribuiscono poco all'energia finale di uno stato quantistico.
Il prossimo punto che voglio fare è che dovrai pensare a come scrivere il problema in modo che un computer quantistico possa dargli un senso.
Spesso ciò implica porsi queste tre domande. Uno: cosa rappresenteranno i nostri qubit
in questo modello? Due: il nostro problema è continuo? Poiché i computer quantistici sono digitali, dovrai
trovare un modo per discretizzare il problema. E tre, infine: la topologia del problema si allinea con la topologia dell'
hardware? Se sì, ottimo. Ma se no, potremmo dover implementare alcuni trucchi per farlo funzionare. Quindi affrontiamo
questa prima domanda. Ciò che penso sia al cuore di tutte le difficoltà nella comprensione del mapping, specialmente come
nuovo concetto: cosa può rappresentare un qubit?
I qubit possono essere usati per rappresentare molte cose. La prima e più semplice, secondo me, è un nodo su un grafo. I grafi sono
usati per mostrare la connettività e molti tipi diversi di problemi matematici. E i nodi sono un elemento fondamentale che rappresenta un punto
o un'entità all'interno di una rete. A seconda di cosa rappresenta l'intera rete, potrebbe essere una città, una persona o un
ferromagnete in un reticolo. I qubit possono anche essere usati per rappresentare bosoni e fermioni. Anche se qui avverto che
un singolo qubit non equivale esattamente a un bosone o un fermione. È un po' più
complicato di così e ci entrerò tra poco, ma in generale, una catena di spin che seguono certe statistiche è
qualcosa che può essere facilmente tradotto in un'architettura a qubit.
Ora stiamo entrando in esempi un po' più complicati. Per questi modelli, non ha più senso
parlare in termini di un singolo qubit.
Invece, abbiamo bisogno di gruppi di loro per formare qualcosa di fisico. Ad esempio, un
gruppo di qubit qui rappresentati su una topologia heavy hexagonal può essere usato per rappresentare le posizioni geometriche di amminoacidi
o catene polimeriche. Un altro esempio è la simulazione della diffusione di adroni
nei modelli di fisica delle alte energie, che può essere fatta simulando l'evoluzione temporale di un pacchetto d'onda adronico. In questo caso,
un registro di qubit può essere usato per codificare diversi stati di un campo quantistico: lo stato di vuoto di quel campo o
un pacchetto d'onda che si propaga su questo vuoto.
Voglio anche notare che il mapping del problema su un computer quantistico ha passi distinti: uno, il mapping degli
stati sui qubit e sui circuit, e due, il mapping della funzione di costo o del valore di aspettativa
degli osservabili e degli operatori quantistici. Vedremo come questi vengono gestiti in esempi specifici. Ma
a questo punto abbiamo parlato in modo abbastanza astratto della sfida che ci attende.
Esaminiamo ora questi esempi in dettaglio.
Cominciamo con il nostro primo esempio. Secondo me, uno dei problemi di mapping più semplici è quello che abbiamo già
approfondito, l'esempio del max cut. In quel problema, il mapping era abbastanza facile per noi perché un qubit
WEBVTT
equivaleva a un nodo nel nostro grafo. Usare i nodi su un grafo è molto intuitivo e questo è
fortunato perché corrisponde a molte applicazioni. Molte volte quando vuoi modellare qualcosa che corrisponde a una
serie di nodi connessi insieme, se i raggruppamenti sono binari come zero o uno, o incluso e non incluso in un
insieme, puoi semplicemente e naturalmente mappare questi nodi in bit o qubit.
In questo esempio, e anche in quello che abbiamo scalato a 100 qubit nell'episodio 3, la connettività del grafo
corrispondeva già alla topologia del nostro hardware superconduttore. Quindi non dovevamo preoccuparci neanche di quello. Ora, non è sempre così.
E se hai un grafo più complicato o connesso rispetto agli esempi che abbiamo evidenziato finora, dovrai
implementare gate di swap. Ma questo viene gestito effettivamente al secondo passo dei Qiskit patterns, che si occupa
della transpilazione. L'altra parte del problema del max cut che lo rende così utile è che
sappiamo già come esprimere la funzione di costo come Hamiltoniano usando la formulazione QUBO.
Ricorda che nel quantum computing e negli algoritmi quantistici variazionali, una funzione di costo Hamiltoniana è una funzione
che codifica la soluzione ottimale del problema nello stato fondamentale dell'Hamiltoniano.
Per costruire l'Hamiltoniano di costo, eravamo in grado di usare la classe SparsePauliOp in Qiskit per specificare la
connettività del nostro grafo e la fase di mapping agli operatori quantistici è fatta. E il quantum circuit era
semplicemente l'ansatz QAOA. Ora, se questo non ti dice nulla, torna a guardare l'episodio 3 dove lo affrontiamo
in modo molto più dettagliato. Ora, alziamo leggermente la difficoltà. Poi, esamineremo
un esempio modellato nell'articolo chiamato "Resource efficient quantum algorithm for protein folding" scritto da
IBM in collaborazione con l'Università del Nuovo Galles del Sud. Un po' di background di biochimica: le proteine sono
macromolecole composte da lunghe catene di amminoacidi. Queste lunghe catene si ripiegano
in strutture complesse che svolgono un'ampia varietà di funzioni biologiche.
Determinare la struttura di una proteina nello spazio tridimensionale e comprendere le relazioni tra
struttura e funzione sono tra i problemi più impegnativi della biochimica moderna.
Le proteine si ripiegano in strutture utili a causa delle interazioni tra gli amminoacidi stessi.
Man mano che la struttura si torce e si piega, amminoacidi lontani tra loro nella catena potrebbero finire proprio vicini
l'uno all'altro e potrebbero interagire fortemente. Abbiamo bisogno di un Hamiltoniano che descriva tutte queste interazioni tra
amminoacidi se vogliamo prevedere quale struttura finale minimizzerà l'energia. Qui ci concentreremo sulle catene di amminoacidi e
su come possono essere modellate su un computer quantistico, e poi su come possiamo ottenere le distanze inter-amminoacido per
il calcolo delle energie di interazione.
Con questo, avremo effettivamente raccolto tutti i contributi necessari all'Hamiltoniano per simularlo
su un computer quantistico. Nelle proteine reali, gli amminoacidi possono occupare un continuum di posizioni possibili.
Tuttavia, useremo una semplificazione qui e li limiteremo a un modello a reticolo dove ogni amminoacido
occupa un punto su una griglia. Qui, gli autori hanno usato un reticolo tetraedrico.
Una nota veloce: stiamo codificando la direzione degli archi e non i nodi stessi come nel problema del max cut.
Ogni qubit rappresenta un possibile percorso a singolo passo lungo la griglia tetraedrica. Nota che i siti adiacenti sono stati
etichettati in questo diagramma come A o B a causa delle loro diverse orientazioni nel reticolo.
La catena proteica è rappresentata come una serie di turni o direzioni su questo
reticolo. Ogni turno tra gli amminoacidi può essere in una di quattro direzioni
corrispondenti agli archi del tetraedro.
Questi quattro possibili turni sono codificati usando quattro qubit.
Sembra un po' complicato. Quindi esaminiamo questo esempio in modo un po' più approfondito.
Posizioniamo il nostro primo amminoacido su questo punto nel reticolo tetraedrico. La direzione verso il primo
amminoacido della catena verso il secondo è arbitraria perché il sistema può sempre essere ruotato per far puntare quell'arco
in qualsiasi direzione vogliamo. Quindi posizioniamo il nostro secondo amminoacido qui. Non è così
facile da vedere, ma il percorso dal secondo al terzo è in realtà anch'esso arbitrario. Tutte e tre le scelte
risulterebbero nell'avere due archi con un angolo di circa 109,5°
tra di loro. Scegliere questo secondo arco determina semplicemente l'orientamento della nostra proteina nello spazio. Quindi, senza perdita di
generalità, possiamo scegliere che i primi turni siano semplicemente 0 0 1 e 0 0 1
0. Con queste semplificazioni, la configurazione della catena di amminoacidi è semplicemente data da questa espressione.
Finora abbiamo mappato gli archi del tetraedro sui qubit e il nostro quantum circuit sarà un ansatz. Ora dobbiamo
considerare come codificare l'energia del problema in un Hamiltoniano in modo che il suo stato fondamentale ci dia il
schema di ripiegamento ottimale. Ora, per qualsiasi configurazione data, ci sarà un'energia associata dovuta alle
interazioni tra gli amminoacidi stessi. Queste interazioni sono più forti quando i due amminoacidi sono
vicini tra loro. Ovviamente, gli amminoacidi adiacenti nella catena principale interagiranno sempre tra
loro. Ma poiché la proteina può torcersi e piegarsi, altre coppie di amminoacidi
possono anch'esse interagire. Gli amminoacidi 10 e 20, ad esempio, potrebbero finire su
siti adiacenti dopo che la proteina si è ripiegata. Gli amminoacidi che finiscono vicini tra loro hanno interazioni più
forti e guidano il processo di ripiegamento, ma non hanno necessariamente indici vicini tra
loro. Quindi abbiamo bisogno di una formula per descrivere la distanza D tra gli amminoacidi I e
J usando le informazioni codificate sui qubit di configurazione. In questo modo possiamo
usare la loro distanza di separazione per determinare quanto fortemente stiano interagendo. Questo è un po' complicato
ma seguimi perché è un trucco elegante. Prima, introduciamo una funzione f sub a di i che indica se
WEBVTT
un arco a è usato per il turno all'amminoacido i. Qui a potrebbe prendere uno qualsiasi
dei quattro possibili direzioni alla luce della codifica della configurazione sopra. Possiamo scrivere queste funzioni e poi
possiamo definire una differenza nel numero di turni etichettati a su reticoli A e B dal
indice I all'indice J come delta N. Perché lo faremmo? Bene, risulta che il
reticolo tetraedrico ha una proprietà molto utile. Concentriamoci su questo amminoacido qui. Non importa quale sia,
ma chiamiamolo amminoacido E. Vogliamo sapere quanto lontano sarà l'amminoacido j. E tutto ciò che abbiamo
sono gli archi lungo i quali avanzano i passi della catena. Partendo da I, nota che un passo
fuori dal centro lungo un particolare tipo di arco, chiamalo a da questo sito di reticolo A,
è esattamente opposto ed è annullato da un passo fuori lungo l'arco a dal
sito B. Quindi più passi lungo l'arco A da qualsiasi sito di reticolo A spostano la
catena principale lontano dall'amminoacido E e i passi lungo il tipo di arco A dai siti B
ti riportano indietro. Quindi la distanza tra due amminoacidi I e J lungo il tipo di arco
che etichetteremo A dipende dalla differenza tra i passi effettuati lungo gli archi A
dai siti A e dai siti B. Poiché A e B si alternano necessariamente nella
catena principale della proteina, questo è catturato dal termine (-1) alla K. E questo argomento si applica ad altri tipi di arco
anch'essi. Quindi la distanza tra amminoacidi nei passi del reticolo tetraedrico può essere calcolata alla fine da questa
espressione. Ma come otteniamo l'Hamiltoniano da questa lunga equazione per la distanza totale tra gli amminoacidi? In
realtà c'è una corrispondenza uno-a-uno tra queste distanze nei passi del reticolo tetraedrico e la distanza
euclidea. E puoi vedere che ho già calcolato alcune delle espressioni per te.
Queste distanze possono essere usate nel calcolo dell'energia della tua configurazione.
A seconda del tuo scopo, potresti stabilire una distanza di cutoff al di sotto della quale consideri la coppia come interagente,
oppure potresti fare qualcosa di più complicato. Potrebbe non essere ovvio, ma in realtà abbiamo finito con la fase di mapping
facendo questo. Gli stati dei qubit indicano il turno, e la raccolta dei turni indica la
distanza tra qualsiasi coppia di amminoacidi. Coppie di varie specie di amminoacidi
hanno interazioni diverse, alcune attrattive, alcune repulsive. Se stai usando la configurazione e la distanza per
determinare semplicemente se le interazioni degli amminoacidi noti sono attive o inattive,
le intensità sono ben note. Non da me, ma puoi cercarle in una tabella come questa. Quindi, in sintesi, in
questo esempio, i qubit sono usati per indicare posizioni su un reticolo che insieme formano una catena di amminoacidi.
E simulando come si piegano e si ripiegano, possiamo sperabilmente trovare risultati migliori nella ricerca medica. Ora,
abbiamo saltato il calcolo di alcuni termini di questo Hamiltoniano perché erano iper-specifici di questo problema. Mentre la definizione di
direzioni su un reticolo può essere applicata più in generale.
Ora, una volta che hai un Hamiltoniano generale, vorrai sempre tradurlo in operatori di Pauli che
sono nativi del computer quantistico. Questo è ciò di cui parleremo dopo.
Continuiamo. Esploriamo ora come tradurre un sistema di particelle subatomiche in operatori di Pauli. Le particelle subatomiche
sono suddivise in due categorie: bosoni e fermioni. I bosoni
come i fotoni o il bosone di Higgs obbediscono a un certo insieme di regole statistiche e i fermioni come gli elettroni o i neutrini ne obbediscono un'altra.
La differenza fondamentale tra di loro è che ai bosoni è consentito occupare lo stesso stato. Non c'è limite a quanti
bosoni possono trovarsi nello stato fondamentale o in qualsiasi altro stato eccitato. I fermioni, d'altro canto, sono egoisti. Esigono che
ogni singola particella abbia il proprio stato quantistico. I bosoni hanno anche spin interi mentre i fermioni hanno spin semi-interi,
come l'elettrone con spin 1/2 o le più esotiche particelle con spin 3/2. Per
descrivere un sistema di particelle, abbiamo bisogno di una descrizione della loro energia. Concentriamoci sui fermioni. Possiamo iniziare con l'
Hamiltoniano che è scritto in termini di ciò che chiamiamo operatori C. Questi sono fondamentalmente oggetti matematici che
corrispondono alla creazione o all'annichilazione di un fermione da uno stato nel sistema.
Sono spesso scritti come f dagger e f in una notazione che chiamiamo seconda
quantizzazione. Ora, f dagger è l'operatore che crea un fermione nello stato i. f è
l'operatore che distrugge un fermione nello stato i. Ma ricorda, i computer quantistici di solito operano in una
base di qubit con regole specifiche per rappresentare i sistemi fermionici. Non lavorano intrinsecamente nel linguaggio degli
operatori fermionici. Per colmare questo divario, dobbiamo mappare la notazione seconda quantizzata in operatori di Pauli che
corrispondono naturalmente ai gate quantistici.
Esistono diverse trasformazioni di questo tipo per i fermioni. Una scelta comune è la trasformazione Jordan-Wigner.
Le mappature Bravyi-Kitaev e di parità sono più recenti per le codifiche fermioniche.
Le operazioni bosoniche, d'altro canto, possono essere trasformate usando la trasformazione Holstein-Primakoff o mappando direttamente
gli stati di Fock su una sottobasi dei modi bosonici disponibili.
E ci sono altre opzioni per i bosoni. Altre codifiche sono attivamente oggetto di ricerca. Ma per ora, ci
concentreremo solo sulla trasformazione Jordan-Wigner.
Quindi perché non assegniamo semplicemente un qubit per rappresentare ogni elettrone? Beh, non possiamo.
I qubit sono distinguibili e gli elettroni no. Ad esempio, possiamo facilmente etichettare e identificare i singoli qubit su
qualsiasi dispositivo, ma l'indistinguibilità degli elettroni significa che non possiamo etichettarli affatto. Dobbiamo effettivamente etichettare
invece gli operatori secondo gli orbitali occupati come 1s, 2s e 2p
invece di elettroni specifici. Quindi dobbiamo effettivamente etichettare gli operatori secondo gli orbitali occupati come 1s
2s e 2p invece di etichettare elettroni specifici. Quindi ogni qubit svolge
WEBVTT
approssimativamente il ruolo di un orbitale nella molecola, che è o occupato o non occupato.
Ma come lo facciamo è in realtà un po' più complicato. Quindi ora introduciamo qualcosa chiamato mappatura Jordan-Wigner per tenere traccia
dell'antisimmetria e garantire che le statistiche corrette del sistema fermionico complessivo vengano rispettate. La mappatura
Jordan-Wigner è concettualmente semplice grazie alla correlazione uno-a-uno tra orbitali e qubit. Ci
sono altre mappature che raggiungono un obiettivo simile, inclusa la mappatura di parità.
Il calcolo della parità di uno stato richiede di considerare più qubit. Nella mappatura di parità e in altre, l'
interpretazione di un qubit corrispondente a un orbitale non vale.
Ora facciamo insieme un esempio abbastanza semplice per assicurarci di aver capito questa trasformazione.
Diciamo che vogliamo calcolare l'interazione a singolo qubit f dagger f. Iniziamo inserendo le nostre definizioni per gli
operatori di alzata e abbassamento. Poi possiamo raggruppare i termini fattorizzando la matrice identità i e il 1/4.
Come vediamo, rimaniamo con termini che sembreranno familiari a chi ha a che fare con le relazioni di commutazione. Questo termine qui
tra parentesi non è altro che i volte il commutatore di x knot e y. E non
dimenticare dell'identità che abbiamo tolto fuori.
Ora ricorda che queste sono solo matrici di Pauli. Quindi il commutatore è ben noto. Il commutatore di x e y in
quell'ordine è semplice: è 2iz. Assicurati di non perdere il segno negativo e otterrai questo come risultato finale.
Alla fine, abbiamo riscritto con successo un'espressione fermionica
in termini di operatori di Pauli che il nostro computer quantistico sarà in grado di capire.
Discutiamo rapidamente come implementeremmo la mappatura Jordan-Wigner in Qiskit perché, sebbene penso sia
importante capire come funzionano la mappatura e trasformazioni simili e vederle elaborate almeno una volta, non
vorresti dover fare manualmente tutto questo calcolo ogni singola volta.
In particolare per sistemi di grandi dimensioni, possiamo fare uso della funzione SparsePauliOp in Qiskit per
creare facilmente le operazioni di Pauli associate da una mappatura. Un'implementazione non ottimale
farà uso di cicli annidati e richiede circa 20 righe di codice.
Ti linkerò il codice perché lo esplori. Ma ad alto livello, i passi sono i seguenti.
Uno, usa la funzione SparsePauliOp from_list per creare un operatore identità
corrispondente alla dimensione dello spazio dei parametri da mappare. Due, seguendo la definizione degli operatori di creazione
e annichilazione mostrata in precedenza, usa la funzione SparsePauliOp from_list per definire operazioni di Pauli x, y e z.
Questo mapperà gli operatori fermionici di creazione e annichilazione agli operatori di spin dei qubit codificando il numero di occupazione fermionico
nella base computazionale dei qubit. E tre: genera l'
Hamiltoniano nella base di Pauli applicando i suddetti operatori agli orbitali di interesse. Questo di solito corrisponde alla
creazione di una matrice identità che rappresenta il nucleo, gli orbitali non interagenti, e poi applicando gli operatori di creazione
e annichilazione allo spazio attivo con pesi che corrispondono alle specifiche del problema in esame. Come
ho menzionato, questa è solo una descrizione di alto livello. Il codice non è però troppo complicato e ora
dovresti sentirti sicuro nell'adattarlo ad altri problemi di interesse.
Ora che capiamo appieno lo schema di mappatura Jordan-Wigner, vediamolo in azione in un setup più complicato. Potresti
ricordare questo articolo da un episodio precedente sulla dinamica adronica. Non ci passerò sopra di nuovo in profondità, ma ti prego di consultare
l'episodio precedente se te lo sei perso e sei curioso. In questo esempio, la mappatura Jordan-Wigner viene usata per
esprimere l'Hamiltoniano di siti reticolari con L siti per il modello di Schwinger in assenza di un campo elettrico. Qui,
è molto più difficile individuare specificamente cosa rappresenta un qubit in questo modello perché solo la
raccolta di qubit insieme forma qualcosa di fisico. In questo contesto, un pacchetto d'onda. Invece, puoi approssimativamente
pensare ai qubit come pezzi discretizzati di spazio dove qui L è il volume del reticolo in cui ogni elemento o
cella unitaria comprende due qubit. Gli operatori fermionici che abbiamo visto nella slide precedente descrivono l'ampiezza
della funzione d'onda su un sito particolare.
Quindi il nostro Hamiltoniano contiene questi operatori di alzata e abbassamento fermionici. Ma per implementare tale
Hamiltoniano su un computer quantistico, dovremo esprimerlo in termini di operatori di spin, non degli operatori fermionici.
Quindi usiamo la trasformazione Jordan-Wigner. Dopo aver applicato la trasformazione Jordan-Wigner, il nostro nuovo
Hamiltoniano diventa questa equazione in fondo alla slide, dove sigma plus è l'operatore di Pauli X + iY e sigma
minus è X - iY. Una volta che abbiamo un Hamiltoniano scritto in questo formato, la
parte difficile della fase di mapping è finita e ora può essere facilmente scritto in un circuit in operatori di Pauli.
In sintesi, abbiamo discusso quattro esempi di come specifiche tecniche di mapping sono state usate di recente nel
campo del quantum computing. A partire dal più semplice e lavorando fino ad applicare la trasformazione Jordan-Wigner alla
dinamica adronica. Mi rendo conto che è molto. Questo materiale era molto tecnico
e se non l'hai mai visto prima, può essere molto intimidatorio. La buona notizia è che ti prometto che diventa più facile e
familiare più tempo dedichi alla pratica. E questo è davvero il nome del gioco e perché ho chiamato l'intera
serie Quantum Computing in Practice.
Non è qualcosa che chiunque può semplicemente raccogliere e fare fin dall'inizio. Richiede un po' di studio, un po' di
grattarsi la testa e probabilmente momenti frustranti. Ma ti incoraggo a stare con il disagio e
a esplorare davvero le domande che sorgono mentre continui, perché è l'unico modo per imparare davvero. Grazie per
aver guardato. Questo è stato l'episodio 5 di Quantum Computing in Practice. La prossima volta esploreremo come simulare
un Hamiltoniano da zero. A presto.